[موسيقى]
زلزال قوي يضرب ذو الطاجكستان وتحذيرات من
وقوع كارثه كبيره بعد يوم دام في نابلس
القوات الاسرائيليه تقصف مواقع في غزه
السلطات الصينيه تحد من الوصول لخدمات
روبوت تشات جي بي تي
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا من طاجكستان حيث اعلنت السلطات ان
زلزالا بقوه 6 درجات وثمانيه اعشار الدرجه
على مقياس ريختر هز شرق البلاد فجر اليوم
وشعر به سكان الصين مع دول مجاوره اخرى
ووفقا لوكاله رويترز فان المنطقه التي
ضربها الزلزال يسكنها عدد قليل من السكان
لكنها تضم سدا على بحيره ساريز الكبيره
التي اذ تعرضت للاضطراب بل اذا تعرضت له
يمكن ان تغمر مياهها مساحه شاسعه تمتد الى
دول عده فيما اوضحت السلطات في طاجكستان
انه لا يوجد دلائل على تعرض البحيره
للاضطراب بسبب الزلزال
من جديد تحققت توقعات العالم الهولندي
المثير للجدل بحدوث زلزال في طاجكستان
والذي يعد الاقوى في الايام الثلاثه
الاخيره عالم الزلازل فرانك هوجربيتس كان
نشر يوم الاثنين الماضي توقع الهيئه التي
يعمل بها قائلا فيه ان هناك نشاطا زلزاليا
قويا قد يحدث في الفتره من العشرين الى
الثاني والعشرين من فبراير تقريبا ومن
المحتمل ان يبلغ ذروته في الثاني والعشرين
من الشهر الجاري فيما نالى هوجربي شهره
واسعه على مواقع التواصل بعد نشره تغريده
توقع فيها حدوث زلزال تركيا وسوريا المدمر
قبل ثلاثه ايام من وقوعه
بعد يوم دام في نابلس راح ضحيته 11
فلسطينيا بنيران الجيش الاسرائيلي افاد
مراسل العربيه بان غارات الاسرائيليه
استهدفت مواقع للفصائل الفلسطينيه في غزه
صباح اليوم الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن انه نفذ
ضربات في قطاع غزه بعد اطلاق صواريخ من
القطاع باتجاه الاراضي الاسرائيليه مشيرا
الى ان القبه الحديديه اعترضت خمسه صواريخ
بينما سقط اخر في منطقه مفتوحه فيما تبنت
حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه اطلاق الصواريخ من
القطاع المحاصر وذلك ردا على عمليه نابلس
وفقا لما نشرته وكاله فرانسبريس
الى الصين هذه المره حيث افادت وسائل
اعلام محليه بان السلطات في البلاد منعت
كبرى شركات التقنيه من تزويد عملائها
بامكانيه الوصول الى خدمات روبوت المحادثه
تشات جي بي تي تقارير صينيه اوضحت ان هذه
الخطوه تاتي وسط مخاوف متزايده في بكين من
ردود روبوتات الدردشه غير الخاضعه للرقابه
والتي يمكنها التعامل مع مختلف انواع
اسئله المستخدمين فيما يشار الى ان تشات
الذي طورته شركه مايكروسوفت غير متاح بشكل
رسمي في الصين حاليا لكن يتمكن بعض
المستخدمين من الوصول اليه عبر خدمات vpn
وفي خبرنا الاخيره نجح اطباء في المانيا
في مساعده مريض بسرطان الدم النخاعي
نجحوا بمساعدته في التعافي من كلا المرضين
باستخدام الخلايا الجذعيه وتشير تقارير
الى انه لم تسجل حتى الان في المجلات
العلميه سوى حالتي شفاء اخريين من فيروس
نقص المناعه البشريه المكتسب والسرطان
لمريضين من برلين ولندن او فيهما بالاحرى
ليكون هذا الرجل الذي بات يعرف بلقب مريض
هو الحاله الثالثه فيما تحيي هذه التجارب
الامال في علاج الامراض المستعصيه